-As a new poll shows majority
support for impeaching
President Trump,
Republicans are doing everything
they can to rig
the Senate trial in his favor.
For more on this it's time
for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
On Friday the House
Judiciary Committee approved
two articles of impeachment
against Trump,
setting the stage for a vote
of the full House this week.
And as CNN reported,
Trump is aggravated by the fact
that he's about
to become the third
President in history
to be impeached.
-We are hearing President Trump
is growing increasingly
aggravated over the likelihood
that he will be impeached.
A Trump campaign adviser
I spoke with earlier today
told me simply,
"The coverage bugs him."
-Bugs him?
I don't think bugs is ever
the right word for Trump.
He's never just bugged.
He only has two modes --
blind rage or spaced out.
[ Laughter ]
Either screaming like he just
ate a fistful of ghost peppers
or looking straight down
to the table
like an eighth grader
in detention.
Trump's
definitely more than bugged
by the impeachment coverage.
I mean, look at him.
When he gets angry, he looks
like the love child of The Hulk
and an old bean bag chair
full of farts.
[ Laughter ]
Also Trump has made it
pretty clear
in his recent
public statements
that he's more than
just bugged by impeachment,
including a rally last week
and in the Oval Office on Friday
when he claimed the Democrats
had somehow been trying
to impeach him
since before he announced that
he was running for President
back in 2015.
-They can't win on election day.
So they're pursuing an illegal,
invalid,
and unconstitutional,
bull[bleep] impeachment.
And then they announced
there was no bias.
No, you know what we're doing,
and it's not easy.
A regular President would have
been under a table, thumb
in the mouth,
saying, "Take me home, Mommy.
This is too tough for me."
I have to tell you, as bad as
it is, it meant something.
When you had serious
high crimes and misdemeanors.
The impeachment is a hoax.
It's a sham.
It started a long time ago.
Probably before I came down
the escalator with the future
First Lady.
-Alright, first of all,
what's with all the slurring,
man?
Trump's going to be the first
President to get pulled over
for a sobriety test
in the middle
of one of his rallies.
Can you say the alphabet
backwards?
"I can't say it forwards."
Second, don't say I came down
the escalator
like you were George Washington
crossing the Delaware.
It wasn't noble or cool.
You rode an escalator
to announce your campaign
for President like you
were at a Macy's
looking for men's underwear.
"I'm running for President.
Also, where do you
keep your dumpiest khakis?"
Third and most important,
you think Democrats
were secretly plotting
to impeach you
before you announced that you
were running for President?
How'd that work?
You think President Obama,
Hillary Clinton and Nancy Pelosi
were all in a secret room
together saying,
"Okay, you know that famously
dumb game show host?
You know, the one who spends
most of the time
yelling at Meatloaf?
Well, he's about to ride
an escalator
down to announce
his campaign.
So here's our plan
to bring him down.
We're going to win the popular
vote by three million votes.
But then we'll lose
the electoral college
because, you know,
it's a dumb, antiquated system.
And then we're going to wait
three years
until he calls
the president of Ukraine
and ask him to dig up
dirt on Joe Biden,
who will announce that
he's running for President.
And also Rudy Giuliani's
going to go on TV
and confess to everything.
That's the plan."
[ Cheers and applause ]
"That is our plan."
Actually, you know,
the last part right
there is probably
the only thing
they could have predicted
right there.
This is just the world
we live in now.
The president's a deranged,
conspiratorial lunatic
who's fundamentally untethered
from reality.
In fact, on Friday, Trump lied
and claimed
that his poll numbers
have actually gone up
since impeachment began.
-My poll numbers as you know
have gone through the roof.
The polls have gone
through the roof for Trump.
Because people, especially
with independent voters,
and especially
in swing states --
I could show you numbers
that nobody's ever seen numbers
like this before.
[ Laughter ]
-What are you talking about?
"We're getting numbers no one
has ever seen?"
"Eleventeen, pleventeen.
Something called a thricks.
That's the first thrick
we've ever seen, you guys."
We know Trump is lying
because polls
have consistently shown that
about half of Americans
want him at least impeached
if not removed
from office altogether.
Even a new Fox News poll
over the weekend confirmed that.
And it was a poll that surprised
even "Fox & Friends"
morning host
Brian Kilmeade, who said
this morning
that he was stunned to see
how high the number was.
-In the latest Fox News poll,
50% of registered voters
think the President
should be impeached
and removed from office,
up one point since October.
Four percent think he should
be impeached
but not removed from office.
And 41% do not think
he should be impeached at all.
-The Fox poll came out.
And I was stunned by this.
It says 50% of the country
want the president impeached.
I was stunned to see that
that's the number
because I thought things
were trending away.
-You know why you thought that?
Because you only
listen to Trump.
And you only watch Fox News.
You're like a guy who works at
Arby's who eats an actual burger
for the first time and says,
"What?
This burger
doesn't taste like horse."
[ Laughter ]
When Kilmeade saw that poll,
he was probably like,
"But I thought Trump's approval
rating was up
to eleventeen thricks.
That's what I heard."
[ Laughter ]
So Trump is clearly both been
watching impeachment coverage
and also getting
enraged about it.
Although he'd love for us
to believe he's not.
On Friday, for example,
he insisted he was working
on other, more important issues,
like a supposed trade deal
he keeps claiming
he's negotiating with China.
-Mr. President, your reaction
to the votes in the House
Judiciary this morning?
-Well, I was actually, believe
it or not, finishing up the --
I was doing the final touches
on the China deal.
-I do not believe it.
[ Laughter ]
Also, if you do anything,
it's not the final touches.
They maybe let you help out
in the beginning
a little bit
so you have ownership.
You know, the way you let
your toddler stir the frosting
but not put the cake
in the oven.
So now that impeachment
is almost certain to pass
in the House, it will move
to the Senate for trial,
where the Senators themselves
will act as jurors.
And Republican Senators,
who will act as those jurors,
are already on TV
defending the President
before the trial even begins.
For example, there was Senator
Rand Paul, who kept insisting
in a contentious interview
with CNN's Jake Tapper
that Trump was just worried
about corruption in general,
even though several of Trump's
closest associates
have been arrested and jailed.
And Paul just kept mindlessly
repeating his talking points.
-All of them have been convicted
of federal crimes.
You really think President Trump
is concerned
about rooting out corruption?
-I think most of what you
listed,
and most of the people
that were indicted or convicted,
were alleged to have been some
sort of huge Russian conspiracy.
-I'm asking about President
Trump and corruption.
I just listed a number of close
associates of President Trump's
who are either in prison or --
-Right.
But I think it's based
on opinion.
It's based on opinion
on foreign aids.
-These are criminal convictions.
I just wanted to know,
do you really think
President Trump
is concerned about corruption?
Just a yes or no.
Is that something
you really believe?
-Yes, I do think --
I do think that Ukraine --
I think Ukraine has been
one of the corruptest countries
on Earth.
-That's not what I asked.
-All the governments of Ukraine
have been corrupt.
-He kept ignoring the question.
There's no way to break through
with these guys.
They just recite
their preprogrammed lines.
Anchors have to yell at them
the way you yell
at one of those automated
customer service agents.
Hello?
-Thank you for calling Verizon.
How can I help you?
-Yeah, I want
to cancel my service.
-I heard "I want
to upgrade my service."
Is that correct?
-No!
No, no, I said I want to cancel!
-I heard "please add a second
phone line to my account."
Is that correct?
-No, I want to cancel!
-I heard "I love Verizon."
Thank you. Goodbye.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The argument --
the argument that Trump
was just concerned
about corruption in general
is obviously absurd on its face.
In fact, as we speak,
Trump's lawyer, Rudy Giuliani,
who's at the center of this
whole scheme,
is back in the U.S.
from a trip to Ukraine where he
was still digging up dirt
on Trump's political rivals.
And "The Wall Street Journal"
reports that Rudy
is still reporting
directly to Trump.
When he returned to New York
last Saturday,
the President called him
as his plane
was still taxiing down
the runway.
"What did you get?"
Trump asked.
"More than you can imagine,"
Giuliani replied.
He was loudly committing crimes
on the plane
as soon as the plane landed.
At this point, whenever Rudy
flies, the flight attendants
are going to have to announce
his Miranda rights.
"You are now free
to use your mobile devices.
And remember,
anything you say can
and will be used against you
in a court of law."
Not only are they continuing to
cheat the election as we speak,
but they're also trying to cheat
in the trial about the cheating.
Remember, the Senate is supposed
to be a fair and impartial jury.
But both Senate majority leader
Mitch McConnell and Senate
Judiciary chairman
Lindsay Graham have said
explicitly their only goal
is to end the trial
as quickly as possible,
call zero witnesses,
and take their marching orders
directly from
the President himself.
-I don't need
any witnesses at all.
-Okay, and then --
-I am ready to go.
My goal is to end this
as soon as possible
for the good of the country.
-I wasn't -- at this point.
-I'm not trying to pretend
to be a fair juror here.
-Everything I do during this,
I'm coordinating
with White House counsel.
There will be no difference
between the President's position
and our position
as to how to handle this.
-They're supposed to be
the jury,
and they're literally
going on TV
admitting they're not
going to be impartial.
And they're going to take
their orders from the President.
Only in the Senate
can you openly brag
that you're not pretending
to be a fair jury.
Lindsey Graham sounds like a
dude who's just making stuff up
to get out of jury duty.
"I can't serve on a jury.
My grandma's sick,
and I'm her caretaker,
and I'm cat sitting,
and I live far away,
and I don't speak English,
and I'm biased against cops."
[ Laughter and applause ]
This is the Republican Party
of Trump,
a party that sees any challenge
to its power as illegitimate,
that's fine with cheating
to win elections
and that rigs trials to avoid
consequences for that cheating.
They don't care
what they have to do to win,
even if it involves cheating
and then defending that cheating
by going on TV and spouting --
-Bull[bleep].
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]